to get married when the contract is like
against you
contract is again yeah so like like
women can leave and take half and put
you on child support So if I was a guy
like I would have a really hard time
getting married and that's what you're
just saying what a man could do the same
not not statistically okay so my name is
Pearl and I do YouTube and she can take
your kids like men only gets sole
custody seven percent of the time and
women leave 80 of the time and they
leave 90 of their college educated so if
I was a dude and I was looking at these
numbers in front of me like I would have
a really hard time with it but I think I
think it's the type of woman that you
are so for example the reason why I sat
down is because some my someday was a
day I was married hi I'm Camilla I am an
event host and presenter I I did that
contract I said right this is the right
thing for me to do at that time I had a
two-year engagement in that time hmm I
was thinking yeah yeah no yeah it I
think it was too long yeah so by the
time I got down the aisle I was hella
confused and I didn't know whether that
was exactly the right thing for me to do
however I was the higher earner so I
didn't look at that contract like it
would affect me to be honest well you're
you're the girl and so like the courts
favor women in general and so like I
from a girl's point of view I want to
get married of course I want to get
married but like if I was a guy I would
have a really hard time with it and you
could say it's the type of woman but 50
of marriages end in divorce women leave
the majority of the time I don't think
it's the type of women I think it's that
they're paying women to leave
succeed as well
that's true but it's like do they
succeed happily but that's because I
know a lot of married people that are
not happily married and I'm choosing to
be single
because divorce is long I'm telling you
from someone that's been in it it's long
it's expensive it's emotional it's hard
work most of us can't be bothered when
you have a contract that someone's paid
to leave like more people are gonna do
it and you could argue that it's the
quality of the woman but if it's a 50
chance you can take your kids and take
half like if I was a guy I would have a
hard time with it so I'm curious what
makes you guys want to go through with
that well you're using the keyword
contracts exactly which is what other
Super Mario Jazz my name is I'm an
entrepreneur and then I think but it is
like right now that's the way it is it
is a contract too but if you were
married in traditionally there is no
contract but you're still married so I
don't even think I personally don't link
marriage to a contract no because you
could be married as a Muslim under
you could but the thing is the
government like the government like
twists guy's arm basically and makes
them get married because if a guy lives
with a girl for so long it's still
classified like legally I think I think
I don't think obviously you're painting
a picture of a big risk and then even
from that Paradigm I think you know in
life let's just be honest there's no
growth outside of the realm of taking
risk so for me like
I see my marriage to my wife or
something I I call it Covenant rather
than a contract and I see it as a
commitment to her based on my love for
her so my mindset is not going to be
about well what if what if what if it's
going to be about what if this could be
something that could last a lifetime
what if this can produce children that
would be it's Wednesday so I think it's
just more about the value that I put on
it what I'm willing to put in it what I
believe she's going to put it as well
based on what she's showing me and
responding to me to my love and that's
that's the reason why I say what I think
is to do with your attitude in terms of
what marriage means to 100 because
marriage doesn't necessarily mean the
contract it means as you said the
Covenant and the love yeah if you're not
ready for that selflessness because
that's for me why marriages fail it's
because people are the value bases are
different yes their goals and
aspirations for what they want out of
that Union marriage that's where the
Clash happens they are not aligned it
won't work no they ask people why they
file and the number one reason is
financial and often sometimes it's like
because a girl starts out burning her
husband and that's what I'm saying yeah
if you love someone you're going to want
to see them grow well the majority of
people that get divorced to be still
remarry though exactly like myself so
obviously saw the value in the
institution right for them to go and
look for it again
even though they had a failed one the
first time I agree with the like I think
marriage is good for families like I
want to get married but I just think
that the way the laws need to change to
make it equal for men in the U.S it's
even worse but here are those issues too
but in the U.S like I'm from Chicago and
there's a case where a woman literally
took the kid to Japan wow and she
claimed child support because she said
oh he's not he's not in the kid's life
legally and she gets 10 like roughly 10K
a month to steal his child when there
are cases like that all over the country
there's cases like that in the UK too
when that is the outcome of divorce like
if I was a guy I would be scared
shitless to get married yeah
foreign
reason I didn't see myself get married
is kind of what you said the way the
laws are today
yes marriage can mean different things
to different people but the contract is
very much there and the way the laws
work today it puts men in an incredibly
vulnerable position a lot of people
don't realize that divorce is one of the
number one factors why men over 40 kill
themselves because they are emotionally
financially economically devastated my
name is kit it's a rocho I'm a full-time
actor and content creator because of our
attitude today
there's not really much you can have or
rather you can have everything
that the meaning of marriage brings
outside of the contract of marriage I I
think that marriage in the western world
has become a joke
it's become a um reality show you've got
90 Day Fiance
you got love at first sight Married at
First Sight my name is Sarah Garvey I am
a professional podcaster social
commentator
and generally are people that pisses
people off you've got all of these
marriage shows and then people want to
act like marriage is some kind of
sanctimonious you know holy thing it's
not it's literally a reality show and so
when people are
um watching these things on a day-to-day
basis and consuming marriage literally
there are people on TV that have 90 days
to get a visa and marry but it's right
it's relatable so they have cooking
shows because cooking is relatable yeah
but they have makeup shows makeup is
relatable it's just a topic Africans
marriage doesn't have to be holy no but
marriages marriage is a union
yeah all right come on you guys don't
think that that says something about our
society yeah
of why those shows exist and maybe the
agenda behind or why that show actually
exists before the thing is it exists
because it can only exist if there is a
market for consumption foreign
so Society doesn't take marriage
seriously and that you can go back to
the statistics 50 of marriages end in
divorce
yeah
hang on but if I said to you you can go
to your greatest holiday destination
yeah the best one you can go to yeah you
can think of in your mind and you get on
that plane and that plane has a 50
chance of reaching your destination
you're going to get on that plane
no you won't because you know that it's
too risky to actually get on the plane
right but you're expecting it
you don't think it's that serious when
you could lose custody of your children
seriously how many relationships so you
have have a child or whatever you had a
relationship you didn't get married or
whatever how many of those break up
exactly and there's so many baby fathers
one night's dance I think so it's still
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible